this that a lot of men have about a
woman getting on stage talking
controlling all the attention they don't
like it you know a lot of men have the
I'm not saying it's right or wrong but
I'm just being honest about instincts
there's an instinct to not like it yeah
there's another reason to its that
Taylor stare which I like I said women
on stage early on oh there's why it's
harder for men just the first six months
or so when harder for men just the first
six months women are used to people
looking at them and for men it's this
weird new thing where it's like why you
looking at me strange showing the first
like right away and open mics like early
on women are way more comfortable on
stage than men
hmm for the most part and then that it
evens out but those first few months
it's this thing of like um this is not a
comfortable thing women it's a negative
they've had to deal with that their
whole lives but like people are staring
at them all the time
hmm I think we struggle with this idea
of like like saying that I think it's
harder for women I think it's harder for
men because it's a generalization yeah
it's harder for that some men it's way
before would see that's that's when they
black-and-white it that's when you
[ __ ] ruin all the arguments uh-huh
you know it was just like 10% harder 15%
I think one of the reasons it is harder
career-wise for I mean almost all women
is because success too early can hurt
you in the long run if you start
thinking I'm good it's something you're
terrible
you don't work as hard yes is human
nature thing wife more for women than
for men because we're in such a category
of needing women performers that we go
earlier and earlier in development in
order to plug them up huh because I if I
need to put a woman on stick on TV you
know and there's you know this developed
women Silverman is like I doing that but
I want to Subaru's yeah sure okay so you
have to get some women you have to have
show me show somebody at home your own
version of yourself right and if there's
women viewers gotta put a woman on huh
you know if you have a lot of comics but
if I'm getting this as a single
individual performer if I'm getting
something five years in and I start
going yeah I'm pretty [ __ ] good I
don't have to work this hard you know
when I start getting more and more
things I work less and less hard it's
another reason why the [ __ ] celebrity
comics aren't as good as non-celebrity
comics
but if you start getting stuff you start
like I don't need to work that hard to
get it if you have to study for an hour
to get an A you know I mean then why
would you stuck for seven hours write an
hour gets you there yeah
so if you start getting these successes
career why I think monetarily you stop
working as hard on the artistic part of
it you can weekend stop yeah you know I
think you're 100% right yeah so that is
the drop off yeah sort of doesn't just
service as he has an individual to get
stuff but at the same time you want to
so I mean as a former Booker as a Booker
all you got to do is look harder to get
qualified women go to Indianapolis
finding this path mm-hmm I mean they're
out there yeah but to prop somebody up
who doesn't quite deserve it only hurts
them in the long run yeah there's the
the problem also is that you want to
find a certain number like comedy should
be almost totally egalitarian yeah it
should be just performance-based yeah I
mean I think if a club has a
developmental project like Wendy does if
the Comedy Works in Denver then it might
not be a bad idea to have all-girl
classes I bet that would give you a bump
for anybody who feels uncomfortable and
wants to learn how to do stand-up with
all that's one of the reasons it's
harder for chicks early on is because
there's creeps and open mics oh yeah
they're not weeded out like there are
clubs the clubs where they get out of
here we don't hear right I'd open mics
it's any [ __ ] freak that's there and
man that is not a fun experience to deal
with that's why think that drives around
the most right away early on [ __ ] yeah
yeah shitty nobody's good and then also
I got this [ __ ] smelly guy [ __ ]
leering over me yeah [ __ ] this 100% yeah
100%
I mean it's nightclub creepiness Plus
crazy people yeah so you have regular
night nightclub creepiness and then you
have open mics there's always a certain
percentage of people that are insane
it's literally it's insane yeah yeah
yeah and they get to go up well I'm
trying honey is your same mic it's the
same life as you oh I forgot about that
yeah who knows what kind of [ __ ] you
getting off that mic on an open mic
night and this store especially back in
the day they didn't fix nothing with
that mic I'm not clean
uh-uh that thing was growing all kinds
of [ __ ] on at least it didn't have a
foam top like this does to hold I had to
change his foam one because it smelled
like my breath I was like getting up in
there was like smell a person on this
happens we had a mic that smelled so bad
at cops this weekend that I've mentioned
to Simone and it was like both like it
was taking us out of it like 30 minutes
in usually get used to her mic Jessica
he said he was me I was holding the mic
different regular metal when holding it
different so we can get it away from his
nose who was there before you I don't
know I think was all of us just like
sitting on a rope yeah